we're heading to EDC the stage is
massive it's just insane and sometimes
you feel really small but then you drop
your beats it's a lot of their life you
know like you don't feel small
[Music]
[Applause]
last night played EDC kind of like wow I
can't believe that just happened
and then being rushed into the Diamond
Convention and it's very opposite from
being in front of 55,000 fans to meeting
comic book store owners that didn't even
know I was playing a festival it keeps
me grounded
and it keeps answering the question why
am I here because I absolutely love what
I do
[Music]
music is just one tool to connect with
people so we have comics we got food
obviously fashions have been like a
continuum that I've been following since
like on the music I want to work with
people that you know are doing very
interesting things in that respect what
they're doing they respect what I'm
doing I want to find a way to draw those
bridges and share those stories too this
is two racks from my latest collection
from Denmark
I've been doing Dimock as a merge brand
since I started my label in 96 and I've
been doing the line as a proper fashion
brand this is 2015 if you'll want to go
out all shiny
we got you plus I'm a co-owner of a
heritage skate brand vision Street where
we've been growing in China Japan and
Korea when I was a kid I saw rock vision
so I jumped at the opportunity to be a
partner in the line and help grow this
business I get really into gaming so
there's a no-brainer for me to jump into
eSports I got involved with Team Road
and met with them they're awesome guys
and at the time they were the number one
overwatch team in the world so we had
that under our belt and then we started
branching out to different platforms of
games and we have like an incredible
incredible organization now one of the
most important things about why I invest
in a lot of things I do is because at an
early age I understood what it's like to
build brands when I started in my band
when I was 16 I was making the t-shirts
cream printing them I was at Kinkos
making scenes with my friends and
building from the ground up so in the
end you take that same model and you put
it into investing in different things
it's like you have to believe in this
brand you want to be able to support and
represent that brand
[Music]
every single day when I'm in the space
to be a creator when I'm in this room
making fashion how am I going to connect
my passion my interest to you know not
just my fans but people in general and
when I'm in the studio when I'm making
music I'm thinking about how do I
connect my music to more and more people
[Music]
out on the road I have so many ideas and
I'm like producing and just recording
every possible way that I can think of I
consider myself a walking sampler of
life and then I bring it back to the
laboratory here and see which chemical
combinations will amount to something
that's useful as a producer one of the
key elements to stay on top of the game
is adaptation you have to adapt to what
the currency is of this moment or
actually of the moment that's right
ahead of you how do you find that secret
spot that's right in front of you but
not too far ahead because if you go too
far ahead you go right over everybody's
heads and you and you lost the mark and
that question if you can answer that
question you're golden
what is all these things that I do all
the different things I do bring to
people at the end of the day I want to
bring happiness to people I want to
bring an emotion that they haven't felt
before that's unique to an experience
that I give them whether it's through
music fashion and whether it's through
telling these stories in comic book form
is to bring that feeling that's the goal
that's the goal is happiness
you
[Music]